Bernie Taupin wrote the words too many
songs you probably know by heart
[Music]
[Applause]
dolphin has collaborated with Sir Elton
John on more than 30 albums during their
continuing partnership jamie bell plays
topon in the new biopic Rocket Man the
movie explores that friendship including
their first meeting more than fifty
years ago that's really good all right
you into it
yeah auto song yeah I read it and I
could hear the whole tune in my head it
was all there I could see all the notes
you know I just have to get it out it's
not my fingers can work fast enough to
keep up with my brain do you ever get
anything like that not really no but I
can write more for you though Elton I'll
just send them down to great Bernie
Taupin and Jamie Bell join us first on
CBS this morning good morning to you
both
welcome Bernie in the middle of that
clip without when Elton was in the
Donald Duck costume you you just shook
your head and buried it and said not his
finest hour
well actually it's funny because if you
see the movie there's a scene in the
movie where Jamie as me sort of makes a
comment to Elton about the the costuming
and Elton's that it goes off on him so
yeah it's your disagreements history
repeating it how would you describe that
first meeting very close to how its
portrayed in the movie actually I mean
we actually did meet prior to that
around the corner at the Dick James
music publishing house and then we
adjourned around the corner to that cafe
which was a place called the Lancaster
grill and but it transpired pretty much
accurately as its portrayed in the movie
and was it really an almost random
pairing I mean in the movie Elton goes
to a record company says please give me
a shot they don't really want to but he
convinces them to hand him lyrics
basically randomly out of a bunch of
files and those lyrics happen to be well
I actually wasn't there for that
particular meeting you know I had I had
sent something down prior to that and
I'd actually met with the gentleman in
the movie
Ray Williams and left an envelope of
material with him so just chance at that
armor on Akismet I guess I love Jamie
your performances Bernie thank you I
love the hair I love what it was like
when the two of you met did you all have
a meeting ahead of time to say this is
what I think you should do this is what
I did how did that were I reached out to
Dexter Oh director and I said can I get
an email for Bernie please
and I have a lovely wife contacted me
and then we set up a meeting in Santa
Barbara and drove up there we had a nice
dinner yeah absolutely I had a lot of
burning questions I forgot asking what
did you ask him doing what did you want
to know I mean I think more than
anything I think when you're playing
someone that is around and there's done
something so wonderful like Bernie has
it's just to put a face to another face
which is like hi this is me I'll be
portraying you you do ask how do I play
you I mean I mean I said what do you
like about the script for the things
that you don't like about the script
this is a fantasy movie yes yeah more
than anything it's not a kind of true
representation of the the actual details
ya know so I'm not a recognizable face
like Milton so you don't have to pick up
on the personal tics of somebody or
mannerisms like a Ray Charles or a
Johnny Cash you know so it's another
depths of that relationship
yeah and how close they are and how much
they love each other relationship is so
deep I love that they said in 50 years
you two have never had an argument which
is I find her remarkable considering
Elton's history he's been very candid
he's he has a bit of a temper from time
to time how are you able to navigate
that friendship and to this day but I
think that's been curbed over the years
I mean he's notorious as sort of being a
prickly character but I think that
prickly character came from those
addictions yes
which which you which you had some
discussions with him about and you see
him in the film
yeah I I mean I'd like to think that I'm
somewhat of an anchor throughout the
film but I don't want to come across
this sort of squeaky clean either
because we've all had our problems and
our addictions you know and we all deal
with them and if
way yeah but as I say hopefully I was
some sort of barometer of good taste
yeah you told him the truth were you an
elton fan before Jamie huge Elton fan
yeah yeah even more so now how so why so
why well I just loved I mean I had a
karaoke machine as a kid yeah and candle
in the wind was on it Norma Jeane was
[Laughter]
but I was so moved by those lyrics I so
moved that by that perspective they also
have the six degrees of separation with
a Billy Elliot I first met when I was a
teenager you know the Cannes Film
Festival Billy Elliot just premiered
there and he was so moved I think
because the relationship between Billy
and the father because I don't think
Elton's father ever came to see and
perform did he never know Wow Billy
Elliot the father turns up and sees his
son so I think it really affected him
Clayton Bernie how do you feel about the
movie quickly I absolutely love it me
too I want to eat again you've seen it
five times already who said he needs to
see it other people need to see it as
well Rocket Man hit station why that
would be tomorrow Jamie Bell and Bernie
Taupin